Brian Cutler of Brian Cutler On Camera
Actors Studio [Burbank, CA]: And cut!
Kenny and Max. My students quote me all the
time. I have one of the hottest up-and-comers
in Nashville who studied with us and is in
our movie. He played the dad in our movie and
he says that every time he goes on stage
he says (he told me this the other day) he
says I carry your bag of tools with me every
time I go on stage. That's a great compliment.
Okay, simmer down here everybody.
[Off-camera] Never step down, now sit down.
Khigh Abner, Actor [running camera] We are
rolling, we have speed, we have a mark and action!
Max David Weinberg, Actor: Of course you resent
it but you should know there's a simple way to
silence all these unjust criticisms if you
were just to produce some accounts and…
Kenneth T. Griggs, Actor: Why should I? Why should
I submit to the bullying of the diocesans offices?
Why should I open up private
files so you can appease
your obstreperous archdeacon who is currently
browbeating you into taking an undignified and
undefined stance and if I do give into
this request I will be taking a serious
I understand your anger but you
should know and I you know I see
your point of view but Stephen you've got
to listen to me what I'm about to tell you
it's okay can I review my my script really
quickly sure don't get up we'll bring it to you
I just want to review this it's all right
geez it's hard to find good
help see Karen can you feel the love you
feel the love here all we have is love
See don't screw up again David
he knows I'm just kidding
focus guys take your time max obviously forgot
the number one lesson have a break off also it
is ridiculously warm in here you are wearing this
well you're wearing a wool jacket what the heck
you have a hole in your armpit or
something you don't want us to see your
shirt or what go back house
okay give them a minute guys
we're rolling take your own action
of course you resent it but you should
know there's a simple way to silence all
these unjust criticisms if you were just
to produce some accounts then why should I
why should I submit to the
bullying of the diocesan offices
why do I need to produce files
private files just so you can appease
your archdeacon who is currently browbeating you
into taking an undignified and undefined stance
and if I were to give in I would be taking the
most dangerous precedent now believe me the the
cannons will have my back up the hilt in asserting
the dean and chapter's ability to withstand
any any interference from the archdeacon or
any of his ordering of the cathedral's affairs
I understand your anger and I see your point of
view but Stephen please I beg of you please listen
carefully to what I'm about to say I myself don't
see any deliberate issue but it should be a fact
that anyone even someone as financially enjoyed
as you can commit a mistake that proves expensive
if there is indeed and made a mistake somewhere
along the line please tell me right now so I
could give you my full support in sorting
out all these consequences I can understand
whether it be circumstances where talking to
the cannons wouldn't be in your best favor but
please know that I'm on your side with this
how extremely kind of you but
I am in no need of a confessor
I should also warn you that if you continue to
persist in your refusal to cooperate with me
I shall feel obliged to make
a visitation then make it
I hope you enjoy the moment when I
present you with immaculate accounts
yeah that's a very irresponsible attitude for
seeing your churchmen to adopt shouldn't you be
thinking of ways you could best avoid no force
shouldn't you I don't understand this this lust
this lust to play the grand inquisitor of the
chapter's house is more than a little distasteful
you are only supposed to go around and be
everybody's fathering god not prying into
the cathedral's affairs like some fraud squad
detective now let me repeat everything is fine
I have control of everything and the appeal is on
course so why don't you go back to your little job
of playing the good bishop and leave me in peace
to play the good dean because I know from past
experience that the role of good dean is one
that you sometimes have great trouble says how
dare you how dare you and since you insist on a
spade being a spade I hardly think you're in the
right to complain when I follow your example
so Stephen let's just have a conversation
in a calm civilized and dare I say christian
manner let's try to get a hold of ourselves
I don't want to have a visitation but I think that
is a lie you've been longing for years to make a
visitation so you can run my face through
the mud and don't think I don't know why
Steve you haven't forgiven me have you you haven't
forgot that I may have made a pass at your wife
and the problem is your wife didn't seem too
upset about it are you bloody liar you bloody liar
she was never interested in you she fought you
off I know she did not you went hard for a long
time she didn't fight at all it's a good thing I
didn't have a drink oh you always have too much to
drink I mean the only reason you spend your entire
damn life committing adultery is because you're
always too honest with me righteous hypocritical
righteous and hypocritical about telling the truth
it's not the truth I speak the truth when I tell
you you are self-righteous and hypocritical how
dare you accuse me of immorality when you are the
one who went to bed last night with Harriet March
and don't pretend you don't know what I'm
talking about and don't act like I will keep
quiet for the good of the church either in
fact in fact go ahead make that visitation
because if you do I will go up to Harriet's
highest friends in London and tell them about
the affair and then the news of the world will
be on your doorstep quicker than you can draw
a breath to lie about your innocence there wasn't
an affair that's not what Harriet had to say she's
lying I don't trust you and I don't believe you
and neither will the news of the world well that's
it you just convinced me without a shadow of doubt
that you are utterly unfit to be the dean of a
great cathedral I will force you out of Starbridge
even if it's the very last thing I ever do
the minute you you got past that hump yeah you
know that little hurdle it really started rocking
and this is why i've never had an actor
in 30 years of coaching get on a set
for the first time and be uncomfortable
the chances of you getting a roll like this at the
stages that most of you are are 10 million to one
so if you can do this here
and produce as well as you did
five lines eight lines on a Shonda Rhimes show
who cares you'll go in and kick ass yeah you'll
get the job done you'd do really well and
you'll get you know I just had one of my
actors just guest starred on on Chicago Med and
now he's guest starring on on powerbook four so
this works guys this process works you
don't have to get your book of verbs
you you don't have to dissect the script you don't
have time for it you just don't have time you know
you get a call on Friday for an audition on Friday
morning you get a call back Friday afternoon
you're on the set Monday morning when you do
back story when do you do research you don't have
time five things to look at on every script five
things real simple who what where when why done
here's a question for you guys if
you are in scenes four five and six
scenes 31 32 and 33 and scenes 89 91 and 92. do
you have to read the whole script no why that's
information you don't need it's not your story
it's not your story you're concerned with the
scenes you're in I love when Harvey Keitel gave
Robert Dinero the Kennedy awards center award
he was up there and he looked up at Bobby and he
says Bobby I want to thank you for teaching the
most important thing about memorization my line my
line my line [__] [__] [__] my line my line
[__] [__] [__] my line my line okay it's
not that simple of course but there's no reason
for you to know what's going on in the story if
you're not involved in part of that story why
what's the first thing about screenwriting
the first rule about screening
writing is if it doesn't add to the
story take it out of the screenplay
you see it all the time in movies they'll go from
one sequence to another you sort of what but then
you think back and think oh it didn't matter it
doesn't matter if it doesn't add to the story
it doesn't matter if what you're going to read
about is only going to clutter your brain with
excess matter why do we need to know it
we don't how long was a guy in Germany
I don't care I don't care I'm not in that scene
I don't care if he you know spent his life there
okay it's a ball buster guys and I doff my
hat you know and but this is why we're here
this is why all the material we have is original
material and I purposely pull material that's
going to be hard for you that's going to take you
out of your comfort zone that's going to make you
break down that's going to keep you from smiling
all the time you're not my only smiler anymore
no no no the smiling smiling in that sequence was
wonderful but you remember used to do that a lot
I have a beautiful gal in a Wednesday morning
who does the same thing not anymore she did six
months ago she smiled through everything I could
give her a funeral sequence she'd be smiling
you know she didn't want me to see what was
going on inside of her well you have to be
willing to do that you have to be willing to show
me you know you guys were furious with each other
and it wasn't about the church and it wasn't about
money it was about who whom it was personal it was
personal it was personal and it became very
personal for both of you in the sequence
and because it was personal
it became visceral for me
okay yeah don't you cry make me cry
okay we good in the booth yeah yeah
we're good that was really great guys
okay Mr. Abner you've got the con
try to hold for a few seconds
of sound holding for sound
and motorcycles
hey that's frontier airlines tv oh sorry
it's both oh yeah spirited frontier I think we're
clear now okay take your time guys focus a minute
we're rolling or take your own action
of course you're it but you should know there is
an easy way to silence all these unjust criticisms
if you were to produce some
accounts then why should I
why should I submit to the
bullying of the diocesan's offices
why should I open up private files so that
you can appease your obstreperous archdeacon
who is currently browbeating you into taking
an undignified and undefined stance and if I
were to give in to this request i'd be setting
the most dangerous precedent now I assure you
the canons have my back to the hilt in asserting
the dean and chapter's ability to withstand
any interference from the archdeacon and
the ordering of the cathedral's affairs
I understand your anger and I see your point of
view but Stephen I beg of you please listen very
carefully to what I'm about to say I personally
don't see any deliberate wrongdoing but it is a
fact that anyone even someone as financially a joy
as you can commit a mistake that proves expensive
if there really has been a mistake made somewhere
along the line please tell me now so that I could
back you completely but I also can
understand that there are these circumstances
that speaking to the cannons
wouldn't be in your favor
and i'd be failing you as your bishop if I didn't
at least give you the chance to confide in me
well how extremely kind of you but I am in
no need of a confessor I should also warn you
that if you persist in your refusal to cooperate
with me I shall feel obliged to make visitation
then make it and I hope you enjoy what you
find when I present you immaculate accounts
that's a very irresponsible attitude
for seeing your churchmen to adopt
shouldn't you be thinking of ways
to best avoid unfortunately you
listen to yourself this lust to become this
grand inquisitor of the chapter's house is
more than a little sickening your job is to
go around being everybody's father and god
not prying into the cathedrals cathedral's
affairs like some mob squad detective
now listen to me when I tell you everything is
fine I have everything under control the appeal
is on course so why don't you do me a favor and go
back to your job and play the good little bishop
and leave me in peace to play the good dean
because I know from past experience that the
role of a good dean is one that you sometimes have
great trouble sustaining oh how dare you how dare
you since you insist on calling a spade a spade I
hardly think you're in the right to complain when
I follow your example so Stephen let's get a
grip on ourselves and try to have a conversation
in a calm civilized and dare I say christian
manner I’ll start by offering some information
that is true and which I hope you all accept as
a peace offering signifying my good intentions
I don't want to have a visitation and I think it'd
be infinitely better for the church it is a lie
you have been longing for years to make a
visitation here so you could rub my face in
the mud and don't think I don't know why you still
haven't forgiven me Steve you haven't forgotten
that I may have made a pass at your wife and you
haven't forgotten that she wasn't as upset as she
should have been you bloody liar you bloody liar
she was never interested in you she fought you
off I know she thought you would not fight that
hard and for a while she did not fight at all
good thing I didn't have too much to
drink oh you always have so much to drink
the only reason why you don't spend your
entire damn life committing adultery is
because you're always too bloody sought after
self-righteous hypocritical so self-righteous
I am speaking the truth when I call
you self-righteous and hypocritical
now how dare you accuse me of immorality when you
just last night were in bed with Harriet March
wait no don't act like you don't know what
I'm talking about and don't think for once
I will keep silence for the good of the church
in fact if you go through with this visitation
I shall reach out to Harriet's highest friends
in London and tell them about the affair and then
the news of the world will be on your doorstep
quicker than you can come up with a lie about
your innocence but there wasn't any affair
that's not what harry had to say but she's lying
all good for you because I don't trust you and
neither will the news of the world that's it
you just convinced me without a shadow of doubt
that you are utterly unfit to be the dean of a
great cathedral I will force you out of Starbridge
even if it's the very last thing I ever do
and cut there we go nice nice
nice nice solid see that's
that's that's some of the best most relaxed
unaffected work that you've ever done
do you feel it yeah do you feel it you've
done it you've got to feel it you've got
to feel it I can't make you feel it I
can't get you to that place get mad at me
it's up to you uh we could do
uh Rochelle and Khigh but then
Jeannie has to work back to back and
I don't know that Jeannie wants to do
we should take a that okay break time coffee
time break time water time candy time.